epa non è partito un cazzo vuoi partite
specie bellagio di ragazzi aiuti un suo
video sono felice e oggi siamo nel nuovo
video ok io non me lavori di restar o
perché probabilmente a quest'ora sarebbe
già tutti a dormire perché adesso sono
quasi l'una di notte e mentre voi
all'una di notte dormite perché domani
avete scuola vj che cazzo fa il
deficiente su giochi ora ovviamente
perché ho voluto aspettare l'una di
notte per fare stack agata per godermelo
al meglio perché io i giochi di voglio
vivere sentire porca eva come sono
carico play andiamo su play ad ora
mirror layers ragazzi un gioco simile a
non so se ve lo ricordate ai hemskerk
che un gioco pixel a tissimo welcome
used to move to run
cresce il tool crouch e la vada kedavra
to kill perfetto questo sempre uguale in
tutti i giochi
quante pixelato sto gioco ti chiediamo
soltanto è talmente non leggo un cazzo
talmente pixelato ti chiamo soltanto di
darci una parte di te parte della tua
identità 22 mila iscritti ti do questa
la mia parte che tipo di prendere basta
ho creato un uomo una nuova directory
nei tuoi documenti che colleziona
informazioni per il riguardo auto
personalità sei scemo è vero mirror
layers idee la minchia cosa ci scrivi
che qualche ora vado a pisciare la
mattina spiega non so please try quindi
per favore condividerà con tutto il
mondo no perché dovete sapere a che ora
vado a pisciare la mattina alcune cose
le devi realizzare direttamente
attraverso il tuo computer per poterle
risolvere si interagisce col computer
stesso e sta cosa qua e molto [ __ ] una
porta bella pixelata sempre tutto molto
allegro che questo successo
le siamo while you girls computer
mirrors horror banane invalid koman tua
madre so se invalid common ricettivo
reset tutto ha funzionato fighissimo è
che sono fare niente più avanti bello
c'è un computer bellissimo per me salve
mi piace questo gioco della casa allegra
caso è successo
giorno mi scusi lei che appeso come un
kebab senza una gamba tra l'altro molto
bello io non vorrei disturbarla però c'è
un tipo che ha creato una cartella nel
mio computer questa cosa non mi piace me
la cavo da sola non fa niente grassi lo
stesso che bella che essa casa comunque
molto allegra la casa mia che non ho
capito chiave numero 32 mila infilo st
chiave di un paio di the cell a salve ma
buongiorno anche lei mazza vanta segnò
che ha regalato gioco ci sono delle
figlie compresa con appesa al muro delle
ciabatte talmente mehr dose che le crocs
possono accompagnare solo 15 dove uso st
chiave grazie
se io ti passa una cosa però la devi
prendere questo rumore o salve no no no
no no no no non fa cagare
cos'è ma cos'era di lancio una chiave in
bocca tela lancio fortissimo si aprirà
portanti ammazzo ti ammazzo
meno male che rincoglionito non voglio
neanche sapere come ho fatto a salvarmi
va bene così ma nella porta che si apre
questa maledetta chiave dove siamo
un numero 2 porca eva numero 3 valore
che sfiga o datemi la la porta numero 3
possono scavalcare di qua
eva per voi cosa è successo hp quindi ci
sono due versioni della casa allora qua
in teoria ci dovrebbe essere la
cassaforte numero 3 alla logica e poi
non lo so no c'è satana qua c'è stata
una connessione con questo mondo ma è
una co le tette questa è una con le
tette a prezzo grazie tipa con le tette
grosse che mi spiega le cose in grosse
non ho capito cosa la chiave come la
infilo dorme la infilo vi odio sede
persone spregevoli documents anni ha
aperto nuovi documenti nel mio computer
bellissimo
ok ragazzi vi spiego una cosa che ho
scoperto andando avanti perché ci ho
messo una vita non vi faccio vedere
tutto il bordello praticamente questo
gioco per finirlo devi andare su un
gruppo su facebook chiamato mirror
layers ove la gente ti dà le chiavi
mancanti c'è veramente tele di mettere
da solo nei documenti del computer ma
che cazzo di gioco è che cos'è c'è
un'immagine della puglia grazie in
questo momento mi serviva tantissimo che
i due grazie loneliness mirror e dove
carmela infilo nota scaricato la chiesa
che fa la mette in input non andavo bene
mi informato che io facevo cagare ok la
tettona da funzionato non ci credo è la
chiave 2 grazie amico di facebook che
non ti conosco mi ha dato allora
funziona veramente c'è niente devi
mettere le chiavi che ti passano gli
altri utenti nel tuo computer che così
puoi tele sblocchi e vai avanti nel
gioco macello e come ho fatto il primo
che la trovate tutte da solo ci sarà
stato un primo cristiano che va beh non
facciamoci domandi sti giochi nessuno va
avanti che è meglio già difficile così
chiudi grazie della chiave 2 rifiuto
l'offerta e vado avanti e vediamo se
c'era il parco da 500mila euro qua
dentro
no cos'è è un piede di merda non ne
faccio di un piede
facciamo le fiji quelle di the forest
oppure lo annuso per però bisio facciamo
lo scambio io io ti do un piede e tu mi
dai una chiave è uno scambio equo
tieni
visto anche attaccata con un po di atac
ci mettiamo anche lo smi talk è successo
perché siamo qua che è successo io ho
aperto il forziere numero 2 sono ho
vinto
sono forte tettona la tettona rimasta lì
è cagato di strisce beh va beh non ho
capito se questo do rev questo è
cambiato per me vedere non ciò che non
c'è più
se mi spunti o io t'ho aiutato po
aiutato non vali spuntare alle spalle ti
ho aiutato quindi tu adesso aiuti me fa
il contrario dove la chiave 3 che la
valascia taqwa cazzo è sta roba dei
libri ai sostituito nel forziere con dei
libri grazie amico mio
cosa me ne faccio di le crocs sempre
comunque non ho capito ragazzi dov'è
finito il tizio ma poi esce ancora
l'altro non esce più
meno male one sono contento sto gioco
sta migliorando pian piano guarda sempre
meglio comunque sono qua se qualcuno mi
spiega cosa devo fare io sono contento
poi boh porcaccia eva tua madre perché
ci sono i tipi appesi come prima cosa
devo prendere a te ti manca un capezzolo
c'è uno scrigno che contiene un
capezzolo a voi che parte per favore
così succedono capito perché diventa
tutto buio quando questo cammina qual è
il problema
l'hai pagata la bolletta zio perché ci
hai una lampada in testa qual è il tuo
problema diventa tutto buio quando 16
sono illustri vede più niente
bruttissimo questa roba
devo giocare a battaglia navale io pure
ci mancava c'è un tipo nudo che gira che
spegne le luci e dove giocare a
battaglia navale york a eva quanto i
problemi c'è una cassetta c'è una casa
al bano albano
[Musica]
no decisamente non è al bano se starò
con questi sono questione acquario pesci
questi cos'è sta roba è una è utenti di
comunicare vuoi dirmi che tua madre tra
huawei per caso un cd di albano che è
successo quindi quando c'è la musica
questi sì si avvicinano è e che cosa
devo metterli nella cosa lo zio no non
ci credo non ci credo quale entrato quel
[ __ ] è entrato quel deficiente
cosa devo fare la è la è la è la e la
risposta esatta
aiutami invece di spegnere le luci del
buco di culo porca eva lercia cosa devo
fare le gang è impossibile sto gioco la
centrale cosa la è da temi non compro
una vocale compro non ero bravo io a
giocare al impiccato è neanche anche lei
è brava a giocare il pick up secondo me
tentò di allora io quando tentava di
risolvere i problemi a scuola era un
facevo cagare figurati se so risolverli
in un videogioco horror all una di notte
dove un tizio nudo sporco di sangue
continua a spegnere le luci non mi ha
ancora preso però è veramente scritti
niente nessuno e mi dà una mano il tipo
è scomparso che va ancora bene per
carità di dio fatto che siano [ __ ]
weimar do cosa è la spar ma non c'era
prima da dove sei uscito dal tappeto
facciamo facciamo così per stasera basta
basta basta che non d'oggi non dorme lo
so io non dormo lo so già facciamo che
lo continuo datemi una mano per l'amor
di dio vi prego ditemi cosa devo fare
perché non ho capito un pene c'entra
qualcosa quella è sicuro ragazzi miei
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
io sicuramente sono contento di
registrare video di notte anche i miei
vicini sono sicuramente contenti
sentirmi eccitato all'una di notte mi
dice ai ragazzi classe mio vice un
giorno momento mi piace anche a pagani
facebook e descrizione giornalisti siete
mi ci dimettiamo pochino video bello
ragazzi